what's the best Raiders finish in the
next five years now that Jon Gruden is a
head coach wins the AFC championship 31
percent 25 percent win the division 23
percent wins a Super Bowl 18 percent
make the playoffs 4% none of the above
okay Charles Davis Fox Sports football
analyst and my compadre from the NFL
Network back here on the riches and
shield how would you answer that
question Charles which question red
roses I was focused on the eating and
all I could see was Paul Newman and Cool
Hand Luke eating the eggs very good
Brockman who's definitely never seen
Cool Hand Luke and doesn't ask that
reference definitely read it again -
Charles Charles what's the best finish
for the Raiders in the next five years
Super Bowl AFC championship when the
division make the playoffs none of the
above that's more man coaching the team
now Super Bowl that's right that's true
man now is that a Tennessee volunteer
talking or a Tampa Bay Buccaneer talking
Charles no that's that's that's my old
roommate Jon Gruden that's that's that
guy talking super ball okay remember he
remember he put the Raiders in a Super
Bowl a year later when he left remember
they were right there talk rule and then
the next year they were in a Super Bowl
a Callahan a what they went to Super
Bowl
come with Tampa and beetle so he's
capable and this is a team that we
thought was on the verge anyway well
what's he gonna do for Derek Carr how do
you think he's gonna help car in his
process Charles he's gonna get him
focused and locked in on if you're gonna
be the guy assume being the guy and he
did that with Rich Gannon very well and
you guys know Rich's career arc and I
think he's sensational now with Kevin
Harlan and then the booth but richest
career arc was he was such a great
athlete people want to be a safety when
he came out and rich was stubborn enough
to not listen to that but his work ethic
his mindset his tenacity his his you
know grinded out style match perfectly
with who Jon Gruden is and that's why
that marriage was so terrific not to
mention rich was talented detective
Charles Davis here on the Rich Eisen
show all right let's uh give me the
Titans chance for an upset this weekend
laid out for me if Derek Henry can carry
it 30 times for and it doesn't have to
be 200 yards
it has to be dirty tough tenacious
yardage that keeps the clock going keeps
them in third down and short situations
as they can convert stay on the field
and I know it sounds trite keep it away
from Brady but if they're trying to
match New England they've got no shot
and this is who Derrick Henry is and if
he he ought to have fresh legs he hasn't
getting nearly two carries he's wanted
in the NFL so this is who he is and if
they can do that and you saw what
happened with Kansas City in the fourth
quarter business decisions are made when
250 comes at you 30 times that's what
that to me that's where their their
chance for winning this thing lies and
let's face it Marcus Mariota his team
loved him before that block he threw him
cemented things for him mm-hmm and then
what do you think is the other potential
for a road victory this weekend best
chance outside of I think I think we're
all looking at the same one that's
Atlanta you know I think Atlanta going
to Philadelphia because I think Atlanta
exhaled when they got in and kind of
reset and realize they're the only team
in the NFC that was in the playoffs last
year and they didn't look like Atlanta
last season at all in LA
they look like a grittier tougher
version and you guys know Dan Quinn have
you ever sat down with Dan Quinn and
talked about a game and a boxing or a
UFC analogy doesn't come up that's
that's what DQ is that's what he wants
with these guys let's go fight and I
thought they fought in LA I thought they
came and punched him dead in the face
and that's that's what they're going to
carry with him to Philadelphia
now we get to see his Philly punches
back and if Philly's offered to convert
a third down last 15 when nick foles on
the field they're over 15
it's unbelievable Charles I mean he
really looked dreadful you look dreadful
against Oakland
it does need that coming frankly because
this is a guy who's played well before
rich and and and I thought that this is
one of the better backups in the league
that you can throw out there and go play
look what I did games a couple of years
ago when he's with the Rams they went to
Arizona and you know how good Arizona
has been over the last few years and
this was in the time of Arizona can go
to the Super Bowl talk they went there
and beat them on the road with Nick
Foles making some pretty darn good
throws and impressive throws so what
I've seen lately has been surprised
to me mm-hmm and you know I got to tell
you man
Foles the way he performed is one thing
but the defense couldn't stop Eli in
week 15 yep had a problem against Derek
Carr and the Raiders on occasion on that
Christmas night Monday nighter and week
17 he got to throw out except for the
fact that every two teams that took a
knee on week 17 lost in the wild-card
yeah that genuinely concerns me I'm
genuinely concerned for the Eagles
because somewhere in Jacksonville Tom
Coughlin is hearing us right now is
saying this is why you play week 17
remember that was always his philosophy
you remember that year they won the
Super Bowl
and they beat New England who was
undefeated I was there that not Charles
that was the biggest night in the
history of the NFL Network where you
know senators were writing letters
complaining about the fact that Time
Warner Cable was not was not
broadcasting us and blaming it on the
NFL for not putting it out there it was
really a frustrating exhilarating night
in the history of our network Charles
and if I'm not mistaken rich the Giants
couldn't improve their position win or
lose correct that is correct and and
they played and then won and it wasn't
just simply to try and beat New England
and break up their undefeated that's
just out that's just Tom Coughlin and
philosophy there's a game to be played
you go you play to win it if you start
pulling their horns in I don't know if I
can restart my motor or get all those
things whatever your philosophy is his
has always been tried for him tried and
true we play all the way throughout
injuries be damned Charles dance in it
carried on through Charles Davis here on
the Rich Eisen show you've called a ton
of Vikings games in the building where
the Saints are visiting right now hoping
that they can then maybe even their best
case scenario a win this week Atlanta
wins and they got one more home game to
go back to Minnesota all that said the
Vikings have a great defense I've got
Harrison Smith on tomorrow's show what
do you expect from Minnesota against the
Saints on Sunday Charles but you tell
Harrison High for me to Knoxville kid
just a great great young man first and
foremost I actually talked with him last
time we were up
rich and I said what if you get New
Orleans because as we all know they
played opening night and Sam Bradford
carved them up and whatever he said well
there's no sense in watching that tape
two entirely different teams two
entirely different way of going about
doing things etc here's where the rubber
meets the road for me and it's very
simple Mike Zimmer doesn't back down
from anyone when he calls defense he
thinks whatever he calls and how he goes
out he's going to take away your good
stuff and he's going to limit you how is
he going to match chimera in the passing
game to me that's that's the whole key
to this ball game for Minnesota
defensively because Ben Gideon is their
third linebacker to go with Eric
Kendricks and Anthony bar I don't expect
him to be on the field a whole lot
they're gonna have to figure a way to
control the New England run I mean in
New Orleans run game in a four to five
like a college defense and have that
fifth guy out there who's available to
cover chimera because otherwise who are
you covering him with Anthony bar Eric
Kendricks but a Louisville both who you
liking that matchup okay you're gonna
use Harrison Smith or Cindy ho I love
Harrison Smith but he's better as in the
Box guy and Cindy Howe you're not having
him cover anyone one-on-one he's he's a
missile it'll knock you that knock you
out but he's not a coverage guy I think
they've got to do a similar to what
Denver did to Carolina in the Superbowl
with Greg Olson and if you've got a
Bradley Roby you commit him to that guy
in this case it could be 137 year old
Tara Terrence Newman you know who's it
gonna be who's gonna be the guy that's
gonna run with chimera because to me
it's got to be a defensive back very and
preferably a cornerback because I saw
him against Atlanta yeah and Keyon
O'Neal tried it rich and Camaro won that
match up every time and that's a very
astute but also very Tennessee volunteer
heavy analysis situation and just
remember at Tennessee one of the reasons
guess that's good legs in such vigor
right now is we didn't use this there's
no rookie wall for two years well you
know in all honesty two is Sean Payton
hardly used in middle of the season I
mean he would he was treated sort of
like a pieces of china like
where we'd see him 1012 times a game
period but no no what I loved about and
we met with him before the last game and
you know he's been a part of their
two-minute offense had been an integral
part and as you said Shawn didn't use
him a lot but once he really worked him
in right but he's been part of that
throughout the season and we had just
you know we had Chicago as well and
three Cohen and all during the scenes
you kept here from Chicago coaches well
we can't use him in the two minute he's
still learning he's this he's that I
said to camara I said held a second how
did you learn all this stuff and he said
well it's pretty simple said number one
you got Drew Brees giving you that look
that's your first thing get it right
figure it out and number two Daniel
Lascaux a backup running back out of cow
sat down with him and said this is how I
learned it flash cards and went over all
these situations with flash cards with
him and helped him learn the offense and
I remember saying to myself
Chicago keeps telling me you can't you
know get this with three Cohen I think
if he's that valuable a weapon you know
what you do you figure out how to teach
you to you just don't know it's like
it's like mr. Holland's Opus remember
that one well he can't learn how to be a
band member then you're a lousy teacher
figure it out I so I'm trying to figure
out who's mr. Holland in this Richard
remember Richards right yeah old Eddie
Thomas because it was Terrence Howard
right but ever he needed him he said he
said I can't teach him he can't learn
this and any time has screamed at him
then you're a lousy teacher in other
words figured out I love it Charles will
chat soon okay I'll see you I'll see you
I'll see you soon hopefully yeah looking
forward to it have a great time with the
playoffs rich always enjoy watching and
listening to you hello everyone hope to
see you guys all Charles right bigger
man in fact gadgets at CFD 22 Charles
Davis the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience